Jake:归位
Jake: Return to position.
Jake:我再检查一遍
Jake: I'll check again.
Jake:你还是刚刚
Jake: You still...
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake:不用不用不用
Jake: No need, no need, no need.
Jake:你躺着就行
Jake: Just lie down.
Jake:不扫你这个地方
Jake: I won't sweep this area.
Jake:好可以
Jake: Alright, that's fine.
Jake:大伙上二楼萝卜
Jake: Everyone, up to the second floor.
Jake:呃
Jake: Uh.
Jake:我看一下你们还剩多久
Jake: Let me see how much time you guys have left.
Jake:你可以看一下你还剩几个G
Jake: You can check how many gigabytes you have left.
Jake:好的不用等
Jake: Alright, no need to wait.
Jake:嗯你还有60个G不用带了吧
Jake: Hmm, you still have 60 GB, you probably don't need to bring it.
Jake:好像也没干啥对导吧
Jake: Seems like it didn't do much for the guide, right?
其他人：不要不要
Others: No, no.
Alice:我拖鞋呢
Alice: Where are my slippers?
其他人：哪有9,000金币玩的爽
Others: How can you enjoy the game with 9,000 gold coins?
Katrina: 哈哈哈我穿你的鞋呢
Alice:你不穿你的鞋吗
Alice: Why aren't you wearing your own shoes?
Alice:狗的
Alice: Damn.
Alice:哈哈哈不是
Alice: Hahaha, no.
Alice:我肯定不会脱
Alice: I definitely wouldn't take them off.
Alice:那肯定你脱那的
Alice: It must be you who took them off.
Jake:我
Jake: Me?
Alice:我哪知道啊
Alice: How would I know?
Alice:给我
Alice: Give it to me.
Alice:你是狗
Alice: You're a dog.
Alice:神经病吧你
Alice: Are you crazy?
其他人：你把我鞋踹走
Others: You kicked my shoes away.
Alice:哈哈你放屁
Alice: Hahaha, you're talking nonsense.
Alice:肯定不是我搁那的
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 杨老板开扫吧
Shure: Jake, start sweeping.
Jake:OK
Jake: OK.
Alice:先扫我们的吧
Alice: Sweep ours first.
Alice:我们的容易掉
Alice: Ours are easy to drop.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
其他人：你把我衣服拿着吧
Others: Hold my clothes for me.
Jake:okay
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Got it.
Alice:哪有耳机啊
Alice: Where are the headphones?
Alice:真是个贴心的小姐姐呢
Alice: You're really a considerate sister.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Sister, you...
Alice:总感觉这床怪怪的嘞
Alice: This bed feels weird.
Alice:就这吧谁家床这么干净
Alice: Seriously, whose bed is this clean?
Alice:反正我的不太像
Alice: Mine definitely doesn't look like this.
Jake:哎杯子呢杯子呢
Jake: Hey, where's the cup? Where's the cup?
Lucia: 扫完了吗
Lucia: Is the sweeping done?
Jake:二楼扫完了
Jake: The second floor is done.
Lucia: 啊好的
Lucia: Ah, okay.
Jake:你可以一直在外边
Jake: You can stay outside.
Jake:外边不会扫哎
Jake: It won't be swept outside.
Jake:外边外边也可以扫
Jake: But you can sweep outside too.
Jake:去外面扫再说
Jake: Go outside and sweep first.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Hey, lady.
Alice:我渴了刘丁
Alice: I'm thirsty, Liu Ding.
Alice:我不喝桃子
Alice: I don't want peach.
Alice:我想喝水
Alice: I want water.
Jake:刚拿了一个杯子
Jake: Just got a cup.
Jake:哈哈哈你们就说渴了
Jake: Haha, you all just say you're thirsty.
Lucia: 您扫的时候我的鱼有掉下来吗
Lucia: Did my fish fall while you were sweeping?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Lucia: 啊那太好了
Lucia: Ah, that's good.
Jake:你扫的时候他可一点都没动
Jake: It didn't move at all while you were sweeping.
Lucia: 如果它掉下来就会不好看
Lucia: If it fell, it wouldn't look good.
Jake:好看好看好看
Jake: It looks good, it looks good.
Jake:喝点
Jake: Have a drink.
Lucia: 没掉就行
Lucia: It's fine as long as it didn't fall.
Alice:你好大的架子
Alice: You're acting so high and mighty.
Alice:还让bigboss给你拿杯子
Alice: Even having the big boss bring you a cup.
Alice:我的天
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake:请请你你也来你也来
Jake: Please, please, you too, you too.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha.
Alice:我不喝这啥呀水
Alice: I'm not drinking this, what is it, water?
Jake:那可不
Jake: Of course.
Alice:不用给我倒了谢谢你
Alice: No need to pour it for me, thank you.
Jake:你不要了
Jake: You don't want it?
Jake:那给您倒
Jake: Then I'll pour it for you.
其他人：哎呦太客气了
Others: Oh, you're too kind.
Jake:来你要多少
Jake: How much do you want?
其他人：够了谢谢啊
Others: That's enough, thanks.
Jake:这么多我去
Jake: This much? Come on.
Jake:瞧不起我们
Jake: Underestimating us.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Hehe.
Alice:你倒这么多
Alice: You poured so much.
Alice:你还不如拿个一次性纸杯呢
Alice: You might as well use a disposable cup.
Alice:哎呦喝桃汁能给你喝微醺了
Alice: Oh wow, drinking peach juice can get you tipsy.
Jake:来干杯
Jake: Come on, cheers.
Jake:哎你你你也干哎哈哈
Jake: Hey, you too, cheers! Haha.
Jake:反正掉了都怪你
Jake: Anyway, if it falls, it's your fault.
Jake:哦要扫了是吧
Jake: Oh, we need to sweep, right?
Jake:对啊草
Jake: Yeah, sweep.
Jake:给忘了哈哈哈哈
Jake: I totally forgot, haha.
Jake:给忘了忘了要扫
Jake: I forgot, we need to sweep.
Lucia: 忘
Lucia: Forgot.
Jake:呵呵呵呵卧槽
Jake: Haha, oh crap.
Lucia: 了要扫一楼了
Lucia: Yeah, we need to sweep the first floor.
Jake:喝这个桃汁他误事你知道吗
Lucia: 你这还没喝酒呢就开始误事了
Lucia: You haven't even had any alcohol yet and you're already causing trouble.
Jake:桃汁
Jake: Peach juice.
Jake:美美不
Jake: Isn't it beautiful?
Jake:还要回忆一下
Jake: We need to remember this.
Jake:他要知道自己在哪
Jake: He needs to know where he is.
Alice:刘婷
Alice: Liu Ting.
Alice:哈哈哈昌平姐
Alice: Hahaha, Changping.
Lucia: 虽然我叫朱立文建材罗马分部
Lucia: Even though my name is Zhu Liwen from the Roman branch of the building materials company.
Alice:什么时候能去你家床上睡
Alice: When can I sleep at your place?
Lucia: 就是大概是那种AA建材猪哥的这种
Lucia: It's like AA building materials, Zhu Ge's kind of deal.
其他人： 这种对我淘宝也会换一个
Others: Yeah, I would change my Taobao name too.
Lucia: 名字比如说AA海鲜批发留给对对对
Lucia: For example, AA seafood wholesale, something like that.
Lucia: 但是就是因为我很喜欢罗马这个城市
Lucia: But I really love Rome, the city.
Lucia: 然后所以我就灵机一动
Lucia: So I had a sudden inspiration.
Lucia: 就是购买一些建材或者施工的时候
Lucia: When buying building materials or during construction.
Lucia: 就比较方便找到我
Lucia: It's easier for people to find me.
Jake:我我第一次家里的时候
Jake: The first time at home.
Jake:我以为你反向推销
Jake: I thought you were reverse selling.
Jake:你知道反向推销
Jake: You know, reverse selling.
Lucia: 我吗哈
Lucia: Me? Haha.
Jake:投了个随便投了个简历
Jake: Just casually submitted a resume.
Jake:然后让我去连续里买建材
Jake: Then asked me to buy materials from the series.
Jake:毕竟我们也要租耗子啊
Jake: After all, we also need to rent rats.
Lucia: 哦其实也可以
Lucia: Actually, that works too.
Lucia: 要不下次您考虑我一下
Lucia: How about considering me next time?
Jake:哎好嘞
Jake: Sure.
Lucia: 给我一个机会
Lucia: Give me a chance.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:你卖什么呀
Jake: What do you sell?
Lucia: 建材啊不是写的很清楚吗
Lucia: Building materials, isn't it clearly written?
Jake:建材多了
Jake: There are many types of building materials.
Jake:对哪哪种啊
Jake: Which kind exactly?
Lucia: 呃只只有只有你想不到
Lucia: Uh, there's nothing you can think of that I don't sell.
Lucia: 没有我卖不了
Lucia: I can sell anything.
Jake:好的好的
Jake: Okay, okay.
Lucia: 这个这个
Lucia: This, this...
Lucia: 这个供货渠道啊
Lucia: This supply channel...
Lucia: 这个厂房啊都是非常的完备的
Lucia: The factory is very well-equipped.
Jake:好
Jake: Good.
Lucia: 然后跟这些供货商
Lucia: And with these suppliers...
Lucia: 有很多年良好的合作关系
Lucia: We've had many years of good cooperation.
Lucia: 就是这质量啊
Lucia: So the quality...
Lucia: 您大可放心啊
Lucia: You can absolutely rest assured.
Jake:好好好下回买
Jake: Okay, okay, I'll buy next time.
Lucia: 您大可胡说八道
Lucia: You can trust me completely.
Jake:呵呵
Jake: Haha.
Jake:下次用EGB买你的建材
Jake: Next time, I'll use EGB to buy your building materials.
Lucia: 对对对我今天早上还
Lucia: Yes, yes, this morning I even...
Lucia: 我今天早上还和领导说
Lucia: This morning I even told my boss...
Lucia: 等到他成为了埃隆马斯克的时候
Lucia: When he becomes Elon Musk...
Lucia: 就是一定要记得
Lucia: He must remember...
Jake:哼哼
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 就是给我们这个EOB带带货
Lucia: To promote our EOB.
Lucia: 哈哈哈笑死
Lucia: Haha, it's hilarious.
Alice:怎么变异了
Alice: How did it mutate?
Alice:你这个是
Alice: What is this?
Alice:然后我慢了一点
Alice: Then I was a bit slow.
Jake:充会电没电了
Jake: Charge it a bit, it's out of power.
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Lucia: 巫巫室水准备好了
Lucia: The Wuwu water is ready.
Jake:哈哈哈好
Jake: Haha, okay.
Jake:这干啥呢
Jake: What are you doing?
Alice:他不信我会弹古筝我给他放一下
Alice: He doesn't believe I can play the guzheng, so I'm going to show him.
Alice:我弹的
Alice: I played it.
其他人：自己的作品
Others: Your own piece?
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:什么曲子呀
Jake: What song is it?
Alice:啊一个流行曲打谱的
Alice: Ah, it's a popular song I transcribed.
Jake:扫扫了一半电没了充会
Jake: I was halfway through cleaning and the power went out, so I'm charging it now.
Shure: 干嘛呢怎么濡染修身养性了呢
Shure: What are you doing, practicing self-cultivation or what?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake:哈哈哈就是这几天过太苦了哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha, it's just that these past few days have been too tough, hahaha.
Shure: 这是什么生物
Shure: What kind of creature is this?
Alice:不是这是自己弹的
Alice: No, it's self-played.
Alice:推广一下
Alice: Promoting it a bit.
Alice:古筝大师
Alice: Guzheng master.
Shure: 这谁的古筝
Shure: Whose guzheng is this?
Alice:我的
Alice: It's mine.
Alice:深藏不露
Alice: Hidden talent.
Alice:好听 赏
Jake:哈哈哈赏一片
Jake: Hahaha, give her a reward.
Jake:赏易烊千玺一位
Jake: Give her an Easyhan Qianxi.
Jake:是吗
Jake: Really?
Alice:为啥要赏易烊千玺啊
Alice: Why give her an Easyhan Qianxi?
Jake:在这了吗
Jake: Is he here?
Lucia: 比较好耍顺手
Lucia: It's easier to play with.
Jake:还好及时停的1%
Jake: Luckily, I stopped at 1% in time.
Jake:不然白扫了
Jake: Otherwise, it would've been for nothing.
Alice:听歌吧
Alice: Let's listen to some music.
Lucia: 对你俩屋子我扫过
Lucia: Yeah, I cleaned both of your rooms.
Jake:对你俩屋子我扫过了
Jake: Yeah, I cleaned both of your rooms.
Alice:我俩的
Alice: Both of ours.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake:你俩屋子我扫过了
Jake: I cleaned both of your rooms.
Alice:那是不是可以进去了
Alice: So can we go in now?
Jake:呃理论上是这么回事
Jake: Uh, theoretically, yes.
Jake:但是可能会补这么
Jake: But there might be some adjustments.
Jake:就是不要太大的变化就行
Jake: Just don't make too many changes.
Alice:那还是别动了
Alice: Then better not move it.
Lucia: 哎呀妈呀
Lucia: Oh my gosh.
Alice:就是他们不是好多外国的吗
Alice: Aren't there a lot of foreigners?
Alice:北北京语言大学
Alice: At Beijing Language and Culture University.
Alice:你想去吗
Alice: Do you want to go?
Alice:下周日还是6
Alice: Next Sunday or the 6th.
Alice:忘 27还是26啊
Alice: I forgot, is it the 27th or 26th?
其他人：为什么总是占着周六周日的时间
Others: Why is it always on Saturdays and Sundays?
Alice:什么意思啊
Alice: What do you mean?
Alice:什么叫占你周六周日的时间
Alice: What do you mean taking up your weekends?
其他人：难得休息时光啊
Others: It's rare to have some rest time.
Jake:啊你们平时都
Jake: Ah, you guys usually...
Jake:平时都可以出去是吧
Jake: You guys can usually go out, right?
Alice:也不是
Alice: Not really.
其他人：嗯也行
Others: Hmm, it works too.
Alice:什么时候上你家玩
Alice: When are we going to your place?
Alice:嗯等你把古筝课上完了之后
Alice: Hmm, after you finish your guzheng class.
Alice:侮辱我
Alice: Insulting me.
Alice:我还以为什么鸡吃完了米
Alice: I thought it was the chicken finished the rice.
Alice:狗啃完了面
Alice: The dog finished the flour.
Alice:蜡烛烧断了锁
Alice: The candle burned the lock.
其他人：山无棱天地合
Others: When the mountains crumble and the earth unites.
Alice:真服了
Alice: I'm really impressed.
Alice:这周
Alice: This week.
Alice:今天几号啊
Alice: What's the date today?
Alice:22哎那不就这周吗
Alice: The 22nd, oh, it's this week.
Alice:不是下周
Alice: Not next week.
Alice:这周这周六还是5
Alice: This week, is Saturday the 5th?
Alice:忘了
Alice: I forgot.
Alice:但我还没搞到票呢
Alice: But I haven't got the tickets yet.
Alice:我求一下北语的同学
Alice: I'll ask a friend from BLCU.
Alice:卑躬屈膝一下
Alice: Be a bit humble.
Alice:求求你了
Alice: Please.
Alice:他今年不对外开放
Alice: They're not open to the public this year.
其他人：求求你给我票吧
Others: Please, give me a ticket.
Alice:求一下没关系
Alice: It's okay to ask.
Alice:那只有一天去背雨
Alice: So we only go to Beiyu one day.
Alice:另外一天干嘛
Alice: What about the other day?
Alice:紫竹院公园哈哈哈
Alice: Zizhuyuan Park, hahaha.
其他人：哈哈哈这么大点劲
Others: Hahaha, such a small effort.
其他人：连轴转我天哪别管
Others: Non-stop, oh my, forget it.
Alice:别管
Alice: Forget it.
Alice:我要看花
Alice: I want to see the flowers.
Alice:你去不去
Alice: Are you going?
其他人：之前也想呢
Others: I wanted to earlier.
其他人：哎呦我之前想跟我那个同学一块去
Others: Oh, I wanted to go with my friend earlier.
Alice:哎要不咱俩找找几个
Alice: How about we find a few...
Alice:那个比较光滑的石头
Alice: smooth stones.
Alice:咱俩玩丢石子吧
Alice: Let's play stone skipping.
Jake:咋玩呢
Jake: How do you play this?
Alice:就是长那种比较圆的
Alice: You need the ones that are kinda round.
Jake:嗯然后呢
Jake: Okay, then what?
Alice:这样抓嘛
Alice: You grab it like this.
Alice:就这样扔
Alice: And throw it like this.
Alice:然后这样抓
Alice: Then grab it like this.
Alice:给你示范一下
Alice: Let me show you.
Jake:为啥要光滑的石子
Jake: Why do we need smooth stones?
Alice:太扁了抓不起来嘛
Alice: If they're too flat, you can't grab them.
Alice:这个还行
Alice: This one's okay.
Alice:这个太扁
Alice: This one's too flat.
Alice:不要
Alice: No good.
Alice:这个也不行
Alice: This one won't work either.
Alice:扁的要要命
Alice: This one's way too flat.
Alice:这样嘛哎呀
Alice: Like this, oh man.
Alice:他没看见
Alice: He didn't see it.
Jake:哎呀再来再来
Jake: Oh man, try again, try again.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oops.
Alice:这是最最基础的吗
Alice: Is this the most basic one?
Jake:啥意思
Jake: What do you mean?
Alice:这不最基础的吗
Alice: Isn't this the most basic one?
Alice:这样
Alice: Like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake:可二楼可以
Jake: Okay, the second floor is fine.
Jake:一楼不行
Jake: The first floor isn't.
Alice:然后还有比较难的
Alice: There's a harder version too.
Alice:但是比较难的我已经忘了不会玩了
Alice: But I forgot how to play the harder one.
Alice:少数玩的
Alice: Few people play it.
Alice:最多最多是4个
Alice: The most you can do is four.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哎不对一一一楼也
Jake: Wait, no, the first floor can...
Jake:哎一楼也行都都行
Jake: Wait, the first floor can work too. Both work.
Jake:现在都行
Jake: Now both work.
其他人：那我先上二楼
Others: I'll go to the second floor first then.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:呃扔一抓二是吧
Jake: Uh, throw one, grab two, right?
Alice:第一个是扔一抓一
Alice: First, you throw one, grab one.
Alice:然后扔一抓二
Alice: Then throw one, grab two.
Alice:扔一抓三
Alice: Throw one, grab three.
Alice:然后还有别人给你扔
Alice: And then someone else throws it to you.
Alice:比如说他扔的
Alice: Like he throws it.
Alice:比如他给你扔的
Alice: For example, he throws it to you.
Alice:你这你你这次要丢一
Alice: You, this time, you have to throw one.
Alice:抓二然后他他给你扔了这两个
Alice: Catch two, and then he throws these two to you.
Alice:然后你这样就得这样就要很快这种
Alice: And then you have to do it really quickly like this.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:对对啊
Alice: Yeah, yeah.
Jake:扔一抓二
Jake: Throw one, catch two.
Alice:然后或者是他给你扔的特别近
Alice: Or maybe he throws it really close to you.
Jake:然后一个都没有了
Jake: And then there's none left.
Alice:然后这这把你要一丢一
Alice: And then this time you have to throw one.
Alice:抓一然后你这样特别小心
Alice: Catch one, and you have to be really careful.
Alice:这个就不能动动了就输了
Alice: If it moves, you lose.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Alice:很多
Alice: A lot.
Alice:然后还有什么这样背着抓的就很多
Alice: And then there are a lot of ways to catch it like this.
Alice:没玩过呀小时候
Alice: Haven't you played this when you were a kid?
其他人：看我扔一抓一都不硬
Others: Look, I throw one and catch one, it's not hard.
Jake:哈哈我试试
Jake: Haha, let me try.
Jake:扔一抓一
Jake: Throw one, catch one.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahaha.
Jake:这不是扔一抓一哈哈哈
Jake: This is not throwing one and catching one, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahahahahahahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈好好好好好
Alice: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Alice:然后还有什么
Alice: And then there's...
Alice:拿着一个
Alice: Holding one...
Alice:然后这样
Alice: And then like this...
Alice:扔上去的时候把这个放下来拿
Alice: When you throw it up, put this one down and catch it.
Alice:再接着这个
Alice: Then catch this one.
Alice:哎反正挺多的
Alice: There are a lot of ways.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:小时候比较会玩
Alice: I used to be good at this when I was young.
Alice:长大了脑子转不过来了
Alice: Now that I'm older, my brain can't keep up.
Alice:手脚跟不上了
Alice: My hands and feet can't keep up.
Jake:试试
Jake: Let me try.
Jake:人一抓一
Jake: Throw one, catch one.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:哎哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah, hahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:天天抓石子升级哈哈哈
Alice: Grabbing stones to level up every day, haha.
Jake:哈哈不行了
Jake: Haha, can't do it anymore.
Alice:哈哈还有左手的
Alice: Haha, there's also the left hand.
Alice:太平了就抓不起来不好抓
Alice: If it's too flat, you can't grab it, hard to grab.
Jake:确实太平不好抓
Jake: Indeed, too flat is hard to grab.
Jake:嗯太平打石漂
Jake: Yeah, flat for stone skipping.
Jake:打打打水漂
Jake: Skipping, skipping stones.
Jake:石漂是什么
Jake: What's stone skipping?
Jake:打石漂真
Jake: Really skipping stones.
Jake:你看打了两下
Jake: Look, I skipped it twice.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake:多少两下
Jake: How many times, twice?
Alice:你砸我我跟你说
Alice: If you hit me, I'll tell you.
Alice:我拿这个眼镜接你
Alice: I'll catch you with these glasses.
Alice:今天就不要走了
Alice: Don't leave today.
Alice:我告诉你
Alice: I'm telling you.
Alice:你想玩小狗吗
Alice: Do you want to play with a puppy?
Jake:有真狗啊
Jake: Is there a real dog?
Jake:那边有有真的狗
Jake: There's a real dog over there.
Alice:有真的狗
Alice: A real dog.
Jake:对那边是真的狗
Jake: Yes, there's a real dog over there.
Alice:求我啊自己走哈哈哈
Alice: Beg me, go by yourself, haha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:等会先不要走
Alice: Wait, don't go yet.
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈你懂啥
Alice: Hahaha, what do you know?
Alice:那边可多那个2月蓝
Alice: There's a lot of those February orchids over there.
Alice:咱俩去偷吧这朵花
Alice: Let's go steal that flower.
其他人：你不录着呢吗
Others: Aren't you recording this?
Alice:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahaha.
Jake:这什么活动这都是
Jake: What kind of event is this?
Jake:这都什么世界
Jake: What kind of world is this?
Jake:地球活动
Jake: Earth events.
Alice:偷花摸狗哈哈哈
Alice: Stealing flowers, petting dogs, haha.
其他人：小偷派对哈哈
Others: Thief party, haha.
Alice:偷感超级偷感
Alice: Stealing vibes, super stealing vibes.
Alice:哪有小猫
Alice: Where's the kitten?
Alice:哦对对对
Alice: Oh, right, right.
Alice:我记起来了
Alice: I remember now.
Alice:白白猫
Alice: White kitten.
Alice:是吧
Alice: Right?
Alice:偷一个回去呗
Alice: Let's steal one back.
Alice:你能不能
Alice: Can you
Alice:哈哈哈偷来偷去的
Alice: Hahaha, stealing back and forth.
Alice:我是个小偷
Alice: I am a thief.
Alice:我不想着偷
Alice: I don't think about stealing.
Alice:这是我的本职工作
Alice: This is my job.
Alice:我爱岗敬业
Alice: I love and am dedicated to my work.
Jake:就像打了成功
Jake: Just like hitting success.
Jake:准备烤石头
Jake: Getting ready to roast stones.
Jake:烤老板喜欢烤石头
Jake: The boss likes to roast stones.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:真的有炒石头的
Alice: There really is stir-fried stones.
Jake:是是是
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Alice:然后就是然后
Alice: And then, and then
Alice:他们那个石头可以缩
Alice: Their stones can shrink.
Jake:放点老干妈是吧对
Jake: Add some Lao Gan Ma, right.
Jake:又差点
Jake: Almost there.
Jake:哎我靠
Jake: Oh, damn.
其他人：进不去吧
Others: Can't get in, right?
Alice:这是啥梗
Alice: What's this joke?
Alice:你都能接上
Alice: You can always follow up.
Alice:互联网烂梗王
Alice: Internet bad joke king.
Alice:你是
Alice: You are.
其他人：去不去小偷半天
Others: Going to be a thief for half a day?
Alice:你说谁小偷
Alice: Who are you calling a thief?
其他人：你自己说你自己的本事是小偷吗
Others: Didn't you say your skill is being a thief?
Alice:我说啥你信啥是吧
Alice: You believe whatever I say, huh?
其他人：那是自然
Others: Of course.
其他人：你都这么说了
Others: You said it yourself.
Alice:呵呵我说
Alice: Haha, I say
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Alice:看还有多少层
Alice: Let's see how many layers are left.
Alice:啦啦啦啦啦啦
Alice: La la la la la la.
Alice:只有12个g了
Alice: Only 12GB left.
Jake:好收了吧
Jake: Alright, let's wrap it up.
Alice:够录了
Alice: Enough for recording.
Jake:不录了
Jake: No more recording.
Alice:那就complete了
Alice: Then it's complete.
Jake:complete了
Jake: It's complete.
Jake:complete完
Jake: All done.
Jake:你帮我也compete一下
Jake: Can you help me compete too?
Jake:我来操作一番
Jake: I'll handle this.
Jake:我手机没电了
Jake: My phone's out of battery.
Jake:忘了充电
Jake: Forgot to charge it.
Jake:给我操作一波
Jake: Help me operate it.
Alice:我给你选择
Alice: I'll choose for you.
Alice:是这个哎
Alice: It's this one.
Jake:是这意思Le
Jake: That's what it means.
Jake:你现在解锁了
Jake: You've unlocked it now.
Jake:帮别人competer的
Jake: Helping others compete.
Jake:哈哈哈功能
Jake: Hahaha, the feature.
Alice:行
Alice: Okay.
Alice:谁惹我不开心我就把谁compete
Alice: Whoever annoys me, I'll just compete them.
Jake:你把他delete掉哈哈哈
Alice:超绝偷感哈哈哈
Alice: Super sneaky, haha.